I submitted this late, this question late online, so ignore it later.
I've been unbendman for about three weeks, and the ecologist did a CMP, which is a comprehensive
metabolic profile, and a CBC, complete blood content Monday. My AST went from 28 to 20,
and my ALT went from 24 to 13, and my alkaline phosphate went from 67 to 103.
Now, depending on what lab you use, the lab, normal, and alkaline phosphates I've seen
as high as 125 is normal. The functional normal for alkaline phosphates is up to 100,
but happy to alkaline phosphates of 103, is it because the bed is all I would say possibly,
but I wouldn't say that that's too high to take bedben as well. So, what you really want to be
careful with bedben as all is if the alkaline phosphates gets much higher than that.
So, I've had people with alkaline phosphates up to 150, and they still want to be on bedben.
Well, if it went from 75 to 150 in a month, then you'd go, well, let's back off on it for a little
bit, and then go back on. There's other reasons why a person's alkaline phosphate would be elevated,
obviously. So, if your AST and ALT are within normal limits, they both actually went down,
but the alkaline phosphates went on. Then again, remember, all labs are giving us clues.
Are there other things that could be going on? Well, the next part of your question is my calcium
went from 9.5 to 10.1. So, if your calcium went up and your alkaline phosphates went up, what's the
most common thing that that would be a clue for? Most common thing that would be a clue for is metastasis
to bone. If you have metastasis to bone, it's going to cause destruction. Remember, metastasis to
bone is going to be lytic. You could have lytic destruction of bone, and then that would also
elevate calcium levels. So, it's spilling calcium into the blood. So, it's elevated blood calcium
levels. But if the if a person has metastasis to bone, they would have spared the AST and ALTB.
They would have normal AST and ALT, unless they had concurrent liver issues. It's a little
complicated, but remember, everything is a clue. So, what I say, you could stay on fat men with blood
tests like that. Absolutely, you should stay on fat men with blood tests like that. So, absolutely.
It's more likely that the alkaline phosphates in the elevations from the metastasis to bone,
because of the calcium elevating as well. And the AST and ALT actually going down
that it is that the alkaline phosphates are elevated from the thin band. And it's not high enough
to warrant going off the thin band. So, I would say stay on the thin band. Rest of that question was
my immature gradual site percentage was high at 4.1, which has never happened before. The
greater site number was high. Right about that number of cells, a band that is high. And the duplicated
red blood cell was 0.2, which is high since the rate is 0. This water, if these need anything due to
the thin band. No, I don't think they need anything due to the thin band. The
um, radulate, the immature gradual sites are precursors for your gradual site type of white blood cell.
That is, gradual sites are esidophils, vasophils, and the neutrophils. And that typically represents
like an early response to an infection or response to inflammation. So, elevated levels can be
from a bacterial infection, can be from a reaction to a medication too, but I have not ever seen
that being elevated due to bed design, but anything is possible, right? They can also be elevated
with different cancers. It can be elevated with, you know, lung issues.
You know, there's lots of different things that it could go off with. So, with something that
if I were you, I would just, I would run this test again in two weeks. I would, so that was a
question last week too. How often should I do my blood one? Well, it depends if we're keeping an eye
on something. This would be something we want to keep an eye on. So, doing blood work weekly is not
too often. So, keep, if you're keeping an eye on something that your, that you, you, things are
often we want to know why? Well, we need to run them again. Sometimes that's why if you go into the
ER or something, you're in the hospital, why are they running blood tests on a daily basis? Because
things can change quite quickly. And it's valuable to run blood tests on a daily basis, you know,
if a person is in a acute phase issue. So, I would run these at least at the far end
within two weeks. Again, just to make sure it just isn't something like an acute infection going
on or something like that.